We're in the Oprah slash
Diane Sawyer...
you know, Barbara Walters
-Warmth.
Octavia.
-Yes, Kate.
-Thank you for joining us today.
[laughter]
♪♪
So, here we are.
[laughter]
You know what I was
thinking about, was,
how excited I am to actually
promote the show.
-Yes.
Because it's been so much
fun for us to work together.
Working with you is
one of the most amazing gifts.
-Awww.
You know?
Oh, my god I mean...
I have separation anxiety.
I do too.
[laughter]
I'm like, I'm going to start
crying right now.
[laughter]
♪♪
Kate, let me just tell you honey
with how crazy T.V.
schedules are...
you've got to be able to
count on your scene partners.
And you're- you're more than
gifted actress, that we know.
You just have this
disarming calm.
Whenever we get the scene
up on its feet
after you leave, it's like
ugh, wait is it just me by
myself now?
[laughter]
-No! No!
There's no fun there.
We're real scene partners,
it's true.
In the show, it's a
complicated relationship.
Poppy and Micah, we're friends
from when we were kids.
We haven't seen each other
In a bit, and then, boom.
We find my husband murdered.
These women, love each other
so much and
there's so much we're hiding.
-Yep.
And we're constantly forcing
each other to open up.
I loved the first season,
but I feel like we really
went there with this season.
It feels really personal.
Poppy I need you to help me
find out what happened to Joshua.
Seeking answers is never
a straight line.
♪♪
What's your favorite part
about this season?
My favorite part about this
season is through Micah
and Poppy's relationship...
Poppy has to deal with
her demons to solve
Josh's murder.
And I love that it's also from
the perspective of this
life-long friendship.
I want to have the gravitas
of this character,
but also have some of the humor
and the fun that we got to play.
-Yeah.
Why did you want to play Micah?
Why did I want to do this show?
First of all, was-
really because of you.
-Oh!
Before I even really knew what
it was I like,
This is gonna be really fun.
I thought, what a great world
to enter into.
♪♪
I think, the thing is that's
so fun about doing something
like this is, that there's
intensity in terms of character
dynamic and serious story lines.
But at the end of the day
this is a whodunnit?
-Yeah.
And who's doing it?
And who did it?
♪♪
There's something just juicy
and fun about it.
♪♪
You're gonna try to figure out
who did it--
-Yeah.
-like, on episode one.
-And that's exciting for me.
[Both] It's so fun.
♪♪
It's constantly keeping you
guessing.
-Guessing.
And I love that.
-Me too.
♪♪
That was a love fest.
-That was a love fest and it--
-was effortless.
-I love it.
That is a two thumbs up
for me.
♪♪